ou est ce que vous étiez déjà en plateau
un jour ou un truc comme ça et vous êtes
dit je craque sur la personne
je vais y aller nico book un franchement
durand michel à quoi bon faire à
l'organe séquelles avec moi dans la
grande d'arca mais je sais quoi t'es fou
train en gare de montoir quoi bah oui je
la trouve très très jolie et très sympa
je les adore elle adore aller la drôme
est très simple et voie on sait les gens
de fans qui nous restent allumées à les
marier très vite au toit vous vous vous
c'est qui barbie d'autres vous n'avez
jamais quelqu'un quoi fantasmes oui j'ai
pas tout suivi
et si vous avez déjà eu alors il vous
est déjà arrivé un truc avec une star un
truc exceptionnel est une star comme
garou voilà où un truc moins avant un
truc oui bah ouais moi j'avais confondu
ginette reno qu'une star au canada
d'ailleurs ces derniers avec les disques
que ginette reno que ces lignes on a
appris à chanter et qui semblait avec
josiane balasko
j'avais rendez vous avec ginette reno
annonçant restaurant à côté du palais
des congrès est en fait mais je vais
voir ginette je te reconnais pas et je
dis bon mais réelle histoire
ça nous fait rire ah bah ça va faire
plaisir aux dés
[Rires]
arrivé la même chose j'ai confondu le
journaliste d'ennemis un techno de
télématin avec cyril féraud très bien
danser alors moi aussi j'ai confondu
gore et grichka cellule sa benhaim moi
je pense j'ai interviewé richard gira
l'unesco c'était parce qu'il veut y
venait pour la cause du tibet parce que
vous savez que c'est un sursis mais je
suis très investi d'ailleurs ils exigent
eux cgi la chine est d'accord tu lacroix
oui mais traître au dalaï lama c'est une
cause qui lui tient à coeur
voilà il milite pour ça contre la chine
etc ont fait une interview très sympa il
est absolument comme savent le faire les
américains voilà très séduisant très
sympathique et tout je sors je suis un
peu jeune donc je sors je fais des bonds
partout je suis hyper contente ça s'est
bien passé je me dis scientique de fous
des races sauf qu'il était il était
encore là et en fait j'ai pas mais qui
revenait et moi j'étais en train de
danser en mode teixeira et je lui suis
rentré dedans
j'avais une bouteille d'eau en plus et
je les asperger de fin notre île a été
hyper derrière le père drôle se
souvenait de mon prénom et où il m'a dit
it's ok variations étonnantes j'étais
tout tout tout tramelan alors rien alors
non après gg voilà qu'elle a jeté
galante mais non je supplie si la
dullague je ne suis pas du tout mais non
parce que tu es ce que tu as dit à pécho
quelqu'un de connu tu nous dis pas qui
oui non j'ai beinheim
j'avoue que là s'arrête jamais vu leurs
bras secondaire alors vous voulez qu'on
ralentisse un peu le rythme isabelle
était marié 24 heures michel sardou
parce qu'en quatre ans on était l'année
du connemara on était en irlande
les irlandais adorait ses deux chansons
qu'ils ont découverte à ce moment là et
donc il n'arrêtait pas de le mitrailler
dans le journal local le lendemain il y
avait michel sardou et sa femme
non c'était moi à côté parce que comme
j'étais en tout le temps ensemble
[Rires]
m
c'est bon moi il m'arrive un truc de
dingue
ah ouais bah ça soit qu'ils vont bien en
tout cas pas le comprendre
aujourd'hui encore j'arrive pas à
comprendre la première star que je
rencontre richard anconina
je suis en pipi je joue au foot à so
foot parce que je crois que les gens ils
ont dit je suis en pipi jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis anti fuite en avant à sèvres et
c'est la première personne que je
rencontre ensuite à la sortie du collège
en me dit tu vas faire du cinéma on
m'envoie faire un casting rue marbeuf
c'était le petit criminel avec richard
anconina il ne se passe pas depuis 30
ans il ne se passe pas trois ou quatre
mois à part quand il est en tournage
sans que je le croise je vais encore
croisé la semaine dernière pointe plutôt
à chaque fois je croise au coni n'a il
va se passer un truc et de jean yves à
toi c'est une chose c'est qu'il va
porter plainte comprend et uk johathan
géré comme il a bien sûr les bons
ballons
mettez lui déclaré oui madame oui je
voulais juste défendre et non parce que
richard dans l'émission il en garde tous
les sorts et ils nous envoient des
messages à leur relaxe des messages de
gens le sait je l'adoré j'adore adorable
un amour ce mec
merci à le voir j'ai vu en vtt à devant
la fnac j'ai pas de dire jamais plus
dans sa voiture il ya pas longtemps à
neuilly il peut le dire à plat je
manquais des gens qui m'appelaient ce
que tu peux
merci est-ce qu'il ya d'autres oui c'est
pas une vraie star mais j'ai offert des
sextoys linstar bonjour quoi anne qui a
osé française du solaire française est
mal pas mal classés qui vient chalencon
les a invité à son anniversaire dans son
palais il
il a toussé et nous reçoit en robe de
chambre en velours etcetera lévis
yannick au palais vivienne exceptions la
bourse est très sympathique je vais pas
quoi lui offrir son anniversaire il a
tout il a des objets fantastique chez
lui à trouver grâce à vertou et ben je
cherchais un sex-shop
je rentrais georges c est le seul qui
passait tout normalement quand on a vu
il a même une appli dénonciation et
christine des trucs rigolos des des
paillons forme de zz des gadgets bien
marrer et ben bravo tout cas bravo oui
c'est tout merci eric naulleau non c'est
global j'ai une petite maladie ça
s'appelle le projo pas de nosy quand
vous reconnaissez pas les gens je
souffre un peu donc ça m'arrive souvent
de tomber même sur des gens très connus
et pendant 10 minutes j'ai écouté je
guette le moindre indice pour savoir de
qui il s'agit ça peut être extrêmement
bas vous est déjà pris pour quelqu'un
d'autre vous garou est ce que les gens
vous confondez quelqu'un vous a déjà dit
il ya des années comme appelé smeralda
cause d'un terrain de basket
non c'est pas vrai parce que tu as
chanté la rivière qui étaient mariés
qu'ils veulent